is this a practical joke oh [__] don't
have money for books we got money for
this little all you gotta do is put in
your order and it does the rest coffee
you're gonna [__] that coffee machine up
rough school but this is the worst I've
ever seen the Franks something weird
about this field you're standing on a
giant dick out of control think this is
funny messing with the TV with your
goddamn computer telephone it's weird
though seeing these kids grow up and
then one day it's just like BAM they're
18 and you can [__] him these students
[__] on the school all day don't nobody
do nothing imma show you what's fun I
can't wait to [__] you up I'm sorry what
we're gonna handle our differences like
real meaning what differences you got a
job and not don't that's the [__]
difference
did you challenge mr. Campbell to a
fistfight see you at 3 o'clock
here's a nice guy and then people are
like hey I'm gonna stomp on that guy
most doublings going not all the sets
out of you
[Music]
snitches get stitches just arrest the
guy care to respond [__] the police if
they got it all hopped up on homemade
maths out the best batch I'm sorry how
do you know that how do I know what do
the guidance counselor don't do math
period what about my period don't do it
that's what I needed the most I'm done
with this [__] camels gonna [__] right
back just get in a fistfight
[Music]
[__] sons of [__] fishes
getting violent I look like a [__]
million
you